if you're a pc gamer you might have
noticed a new setting popping up in your
games as of late
dlss and because you clicked on this
video you probably
saw that setting and went i don't know
what this is
should i turn it on what does it do well
that's what we're going to answer for
you
up front let me just say that like with
other nvidia features such as ray
tracing
dlss is only available on the rtx 20 and
30 series of graphics cards
and while not as visually eye-catching
it has the potential to be even more
impactful
in your game experience dlss is an
ai-based image upscaling tool created by
nvidia
it stands for deep learning super
sampling
traditional super sampling is a
technique where you have a game running
at a higher
internal resolution than what's
displayed on your monitor
this is most commonly used as
anti-aliasing to help remove
jagged edges you can also manually do
super sampling yourself using your
graphics card
settings so while your monitor might
only be 1080p
the game could be running in 4k gamers
use this to create
crisp sharper looking image quality in
games
but it requires beefy hardware but say
you are in the opposite camp
and are someone with a less powerful
machine and want to adequately run games
on a 4k
display this is where dlss comes
in as a solution using ai machine
learning enabled by
nvidia's rtx video cards that have
ai-based
tensor cores dlss takes a target
resolution and displays an image of that
quality while using a lower base
resolution
so say you're like me and have a
computer that can run games at 1440p
no problem but starts to struggle when
displaying at 4k
but i have a nice 4k tv that i sometimes
like to play games on
by using dlss my 1440p game
is reconstructed in real time to 4k with
less of a computational cost it would
take to run the game
natively at 4k now 4k gaming on my tv
is possible without needing to upgrade
my gpu
this is the type of situation dlss is
designed for
players with an rtx card and supported
games can use this ai based rendering
technique
to enjoy higher resolutions without
needing to break the bank on their
hardware
and it's only going to become more
necessary when ak displays become more
prominent because
lord knows i won't be able to run games
natively at ak
for a very long time of course this
isn't just about
4k and 8k you can use dlss to boost even
1440p
as well which is great if you want to
lighten the load on resolution
so you can use other enhancements such
as ray tracing
it's some impressive tech and unless i'm
trying really hard and comparing screens
i've never been able to tell the
resolution was being digitally enhanced
while playing
what i am noticing is those sweet extra
frames i'm getting
so what do you need to run dlss as
previously mentioned this is nvidia tech
and you will need an nvidia card to use
it specifically an rtx 20 or 30 series
sorry gtx 10 series users games also
need to support it
some of the best examples at the time of
this video include
control metro exodus death stranding
watchdog's legion and black ops cold war
as time goes on more games will support
it such as the upcoming cyberpunk 2077
also keep in mind that while dlss cuts
down on hardware strain
it's not magic and you still want a
decently powerful pc
which i assume you have if you have an
rtx 20 or 30
series card but it's worth mentioning
and that's the long and short of it
if you're somebody with a fancy new 4k
tv or monitor then dlss is a great tool
to keep your games running smooth while
taking advantage of that sweet higher
resolution hopefully you found this
video informative
we have other tech breakdowns that
explain things like teraflops or
hdmi 2.1 so check those out if you're
hungry for more knowledge
[Music]
you